قال مراسل الجزيره ان الهيئه العامه
للكنيست ستصوت غدا الاثنين على مقترح لحجب
الثقه عن الحكومه قدمه زعيم المعارضه
يائير لابيد وكانت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه
قد ذكرت ان حزب هناك مستقبل سيطرح غدا
بالكنيست اقتراحا بحجب الثقه عن حكومه
نتنياهو ونقلت عن بيان للحزب ان الاقتراح
ياتي على وقع قرار الحكومه طرح ما وصفها
بال يه المخزيه
للتصويت ينضم الينا من القدس احمد الطيبي
رئيس كتله الجبهه العربيه للتغيير في
الكنيست الاسرائيلي دكتور احمد مصير حجب
الثقه المتوقع غدا عن الحكومه هل نضجت
الظروف باتجاه حجب الثقه عن
الحكومه فقط للتصحيح ليس فقط يش عتيد
يقدمه حجب الثقه غدا وانما نحن كتله
الجبهه والعربيه للتغيير نتقدم غدا ايضا
باقتراح حجم ثقه
بسبب المناورات والرفض لبنيامين نتنياهو
لوقف الحرب ورفضه لاتمام صفقه تبادل بين
جانبين
وجيد ان هناك بدء لعمليه حجب ثقه نامل ان
يكون هذا اسبوع تلو اسبوع حتى يتم في
نهايه المطاف اسقاط هذه الحكومه نحن ندرك
انه غدا لن يتم انجاح هذا الاقتراح
لانه الائتلاف عدا عن القاعده
64 الاساسيه هناك ايضا حزب المعسكر الرسمي
لجنس ولذلك سيصوت ضد هذا ضد هذه
الاقتراحات المطرو روحه غدا ولكن جيد ان
يبدا هذا الجدل في الكنيست وفي الشارع
الاسرائيلي حول انعدام الثقه المتنامي في
هذع الثقه موضوع الثقه موضوع محسوم داخل
الكنيست بمعنى معلوم من يؤيد رئيس الحكومه
والحكومه الى حد الان ومن لا يؤيد هذه
الحكومه العدد حسب ما ذكرت لا يزال لصالح
من يؤيدون هذه الحكومه عندما تتحدثون عن
ان هذا التحرك بح ذاته جيد ما هو المفيد
فيه كتحرك لطالما لا يستطيع الوصول الى
حجب
الثقه نعم هي قضيه راي عام بمعنى هذا ضغط
جماهيري ايضا وبرلماني على هذه الحكومه
حتى الاسبوع
الماضي منذ بدء هذا هذه الحرب والعدوان لم
يكن هناك لم تطرح اقتراحات حجب ثقه كان
هناك جو من ال الفاق العام ما عدانا نحن
كنا خارج الوفاق العام الذي يؤيد الحرب
منذ اللحظه الاولى كلنا في كتله الجبهه
وال العربيه التغيير يجب وقف
هذه الحرب والان نطرح ذلك عبر اقتراح حجب
الثقه القضيه ايضا التي ستطرحها الاحزاب
الاخرى كمان يا ش عتيد واحنا هي قضيه
الرهائن
والمحتجزين اللي اصبحت بدلا من ان تكون
قضيه وفاق عام في المجتمع الاسرائيلي
اصبحت قضيه خلافيه مع مع مرور الوقت منذ
السابع من اكتوبر لدرجه ان بنيامين
نتنياهو رئيس الوزراء ينتقد علنا عائلات
طيب رئ وربما هذا للمره الاولى ينتقد بشكل
صريح العائلات والتحركات التي يقومون بح
ما دلد ذلك
دكتور انا اريد ان اشير الى ظاهره او الى
تصريحين اولا انتقاده للعائلات وثانيا
انتقاده لدوله قطر عشيه الاجتماع في باريس
اليوم اللي هدفه اتمام صفقه والدور
الاساسي والمحوري لقطر في الصفقه السابقه
والاتفاق السابق وهذا الاتفاق اعتقد انه
نتنياهو لم يقل ذلك بالخطا هو جاهر بالامس
في بالتسريب الذي سرب له بصوته في لقاءه
مع العائلات انه ينتقد قطر هناك شعور بانه
يعمل ذلك لانه ليس معنيا الان كقضيه اولى
بصفقه تبادل وانما باستمرار هذه الحرب
لانه استمرار الحرب مربوط باستمرار هذه
الحكومه وباستمرار بنيامين نتنياهو رئيسا
للحكومه بقاءه السياسي مرتبط باستمرار هذه
الحرب ولذلك هو معني باطاله امد هذه الحرب
وهذا العدوان طيب دكتور احمد تحركات في
الشارع لم تعد تقتصر فقط على المطالبه ب
وضع الاسرى اولويه لدى الحكومه بل ايضا
تطالب باستقاله هذه الحكومه تحركات داخل
الكنيست ما كنا نشاهده من اعتراضات من
لابيد
وغيره بدا ينعكس داخل الكنيست الاسرائلي
كل هذه التحركات الى اين يمكن ان تؤدي وما
هي انعكاساتها على الحرب مستمره في قطاع
غزه هناك شرخ في المجتمع الاسرائيلي من
حاله الوفاق ما بعد صدمه 7 اكتوبر اللي
مسؤول عنها نتنياهو وكان في اجماع انه
المسؤول عن هذا الفشل الذريع امنيا
وسياسيا وعسكريا بنيامين نتنياهو الان
تغيرت الاجواء صار في انقسام واضح بالشارع
من يؤيد بنيامين نتنياهو يعارض المظاهرات
مظاهره العائلات ان يؤيد بنيامين نتنياهو
يعارض مثلا تصويت اهارون براك
في المحكمه في لهاي من يؤيد بنيامين
نتنياهو لا يقول ان الصفقه هي اهم شيء هو
بينما يقولون انه استمرار الحرب والانتصار
المطلق المطلق هذا
تصريح مؤخرا لنتنياهو
وحاشيته على حماس هم يدركون انه حتى الجيش
يقول انه هذا غير ممكن ولكن هذا يطيل امد
الحرب وهذا ما يهم بنيامين نتنياهو مع
انتقاد الاداره الامريكيه لهذه الاطاله مع
انه هي مستمره بتزويد حكومه اسرائيل
بالاسلحه التي تطيل هي الاخرى امد هذه
الحرب وتساعد على تنفيذ جرائم حرب شكرا لك
دكتور احمد الطيبي رئيس كتله
الجبهه العربيه للتغيير في الكنيسه
الاسرائيلي